i
[Música]
cuando me preguntan cuáles son los
ingredientes de la receta del éxito
me pongo a reflexionar no vengo de una
familia con experiencia de repostería ni
los pasteles son recetas de mi abuela
no ella fue quien supo sembrar en mí
algo valioso
la pasión por hacer las cosas bien y con
ese amor de agradar aprendí de ella
observando y escuchando
ella cocinaba a fuego lento preparaba
todo con mucho esmero le gustaba que
todo quedara perfecto era fácil para sus
comensales percibir que todo había sido
hecho con mucho amor
mi abuelita
siempre fue fiel a sus convicciones
aunque todas las circunstancias
estuvieran en su contra pobreza trabajo
fuerte sin futuro soledad
ante los tropiezos y sinsabores sacaba
fuerzas y los convertía en aprendizaje
su recuerdo ha sido la columna vertebral
que me ha sostenido siempre quien dice
que el ejemplo arrastra
encontré gran enseñanza en su diario
vivir oración dos veces al día cocinar
como ángel arroz y fríjol con sabor a
filete o salmón prime que aún hoy añoro
después de tantos años
y siempre agradecer y bendecir todo
día a día fue transmitiendo me los
ingredientes mágicos
amor dedicación constancia fidelidad y
disciplina
me enseñó a sacar algo positivo de las
frustraciones y sinsabores a construir a
partir de lo que tenía y no de lo que me
hacía falta
a preguntarme como si nunca justificando
el por qué no
con todas estas lecciones aprendidas
entre sus cuidados y mimos y adquiriendo
sin darme cuenta entonces los
ingredientes de la receta del éxito
hacer unos años
mi café
tuve cuatro hijos y un día de 1985
caminando con unas amigas para hacer
ejercicio les comenté en mi inquietud
necesitaba aumentar mis ingresos para
solventar los gastos de mi familia
principalmente los destinados a la
educación de mis hijos ya que sabían de
mi preocupación por darles una mejor
calidad de vida de la que yo había
tenido
y de ella surgió la idea de que yo
comenzar a hacer los países que
acostumbraba a hornear para mi familia y
amigos pero individuales fáciles de
transportar y por supuesto más
económicos la idea me pareció muy
interesante tanto que al día siguiente
al salir de la escuela donde daba clases
pasé a una tienda de autoservicio
y ahí comenzó la historia invirtiendo
250 pesos unos 12 dólares con los que
compré los ingredientes necesarios para
preparar los país de queso incluyendo
los moldes individuales para preparar
los países de queso y manzana que tanto
gustaban a quienes lo probaba
y mientras se va agregando ingredientes
al carrito una inspiración especial me
invadía sentía la pasión y enjundia que
acompañan al surgimiento de algo grande
con la seguridad de que lo iba a lograr
superando cualquier obstáculo que se me
presentara en el camino
y esa tarde en mi casa salieron del
horno los primeros 12 países
individuales
llegó la hora de salir a caminar con mis
amigas y con tan buena fortuna a los
pocos minutos comenzó a lloviznar
y yo les comenté les invite a pasar a la
casa les platiqué que tenía listo los
países que me habían sugerido
individuales que me habían sugerido
así lo hicimos les compartí a algunos
les encantaron me compraron todos en ese
mismo momento y me encargaron más para
el día siguiente y así continúe
comprando los ingredientes después de
clases preparando cada vez más país así
fue creciendo la demanda después de seis
meses de intenso trabajo
tuve que tomar la decisión de dejar mi
plaza federal de maestra para dedicarme
de lleno a mi recién descubierta pasión
la repostería fina
después de seis años de trabajar en la
casa primero la cocina una recámara
después la sala y el comedor tuve la
necesidad de adquirir un lugar para
producir y encontré una casa pequeña
cerca de donde yo vivía y la adapte como
una pequeña fábrica
ese fue mi primer punto de venta oficial
mis clientes me pedían otros productos y
fuimos agregando brownies panes pasteles
es la era antes de internet no era fácil
encontrar toda esa gama de recetas como
ahora sin embargo nunca le dije que no a
nadie
tengo muchas anécdotas de frustraciones
como la primera vez que una amiga me
encargó un pastel de foto yo muy
entusiasmada
fui a comprar todos los ingredientes y
de regreso a casa me puse a preparar mi
pastel de fotos con mucho esmero
dedicación y entusiasmo
a terminarlo decidí llevarlo
inmediatamente para evitar que alguno de
mis hijos lo dañará lo puse en la
cajuela de mi auto yo muy orgullosa de
mi obra y me dirigí a casa de mi amiga
al llegar toque en la puerta y mientras
ella venía por su pastel yo abría la
cajuela del auto
y sorpresa el pastel de folch estaba
todo derretido
la verdad no recuerdo que le dije a mi
amiga pero sentí mucha frustración
hijo la enseñanza de mi abuelita
decidí buscar el cómo sí y ahora hasta
entregamos nuestros pasteles de fotos en
moto
su refrán vísteme despacio que tengo
prisa me ha ayudado muchísimo en la vida
al pastel de folk derretido tenía que
darle su tiempo de reposo y enfriamiento
para que así fuera más fácil y seguro
transportarlo
aprendí
y decidí aprender seguir trabajando con
mi abuelita con mucho amor y dedicación
preocupada ocupada principalmente
en encantar a quien probará mis papeles
decidí innovar abriendo una nueva ruta
de distribución para acercarnos a
nuestros clientes y así comenzamos a
entregar nuestros pasteles en cines
cafeterías colegios y universidades
seguimos creciendo
y en el año 2003 construimos una fábrica
de producción que fue inaugurada al año
siguiente una de las más grandes en su
ramo en el sureste mexicano
en la actualidad damos trabajo a más de
500 colaboradores y tenemos presencia en
los estados de yucatán campeche quintana
roo y tabasco
nuestra visión es llegar a toda la
república mexicana
aprendí que las cosas importantes en la
vida
son como un árbol de mango siembra la
semilla abonas y cuidas la tierra pero
no ves frutos inmediatamente sólo años
después intenso amor y dedicación
comienzas a ver los frutos
lo mismo sucede en los negocios quien
quiere comerse las ramas nunca
disfrutará de los verdaderos frutos
en estos 34 años he tenido muchos retos
frustraciones y sinsabores que he
convertido en aprendizaje alegrías y
muchas bendiciones
abuelita gracias porque con tu ejemplo
de vida me enseñaste la verdadera receta
del éxito
[Aplausos]